oh I love you you're so sweet
wish I could hug you grab your tissues
folks because Camila Kibeho and Shawn
Mendes are about to give you all those
feel-good feels on Monday Ryan Seacrest
hit up Instagram sharing tons of pics
and clips of the lovebirds who are
quarantined together in Miami video
chatting with patients at the Children's
National Hospital it's the most fun it's
the most minor we are here
he made broccoli eggs today we haven't
run abroad eunuch it sounds terrible but
it tasted great I am NOT here for
broccoli eggs but I am so here for Sean
Milla's crazy cute act of kindness and
so is Ryan their lives with Kelly and
Ryan co-host who organized the whole
surprise posted the sweet moments to
Instagram alongside the caption when you
answer a video call and Camilla Kibeho
and Shawn Mendes are on the other end
let's just say the happy tears are still
flowing at Children's National oh I love
you you're so sweet but this isn't the
only way the lovebirds have been giving
back as they self isolate amid the
corona virus pandemic we are going to
sing a few songs today because social
distancing doesn't have to be born no it
doesn't the two performed a live concert
for their fans on Instagram this is a
crazy time and we're all gonna come out
of this together we're gonna pull
through
and we're gonna try
connect and make each other smile in the
mean time
and so that's what this is for so we
will go flat and sharp yes and we will
miss a couple we will entertain you but
we can't say it's gonna be exactly they
won't um
agree to disagree they sounded pretty
damn good to me and if all that didn't
have you falling in love check this out
after the Havana singer announced that
she had to postpone her upcoming romance
tour writing on Instagram in part quote
we can't start rehearsals without
putting people at risk and with so much
up in the air and no real definitive end
in sight I feel this is the responsible
thing to do she concluded her message
urging fans to be gentle and loving and
kind to yourself
Shawn shared a similar message on
Instagram encouraging fans to take care
of themselves hey guys just want to say
hello I'm sending all of my love out to
every single one of you please take care
of each other and take care of
yourselves I love you so much
he also announced that the Shawn Mendes
foundation would be aiding coronavirus
relief efforts again I just want to say
be patient with yourself please do
because it's it's just craziness and
yeah give yourself the patience and love
that you deserve right now yep and as
human beings we're really coming
together I think so we really are yeah
that's the only and that's the only way
we get through these kinds of things is
together not together
[Music]